um
hi everyone and welcome to the virtual
edition of our year-round screening
series film indented presents
i'm rachel bleemer director of events
for film independent before we get
started for today i have to give some
praise to our supporters thank you to
our incredible lead sponsor the
hollywood foreign press association
our screening partner vision media and
our media partner the los angeles times
i'm pleased to introduce our moderator
for today please welcome katie rice
[Laughter]
oh that's it you're on now
[Laughter]
well okay so since we're here um
you know we're doing all this stuff
online i'm sure you've been doing a lot
of uh
just q and a's online things like that
how online were all of you before you
started work on this film because
i think this film kind of demonstrates a
type of person who we would call
extremely online
um i i was not online at all i think
giorgio is kind of the
i mean giorgio and karen i think are a
little bit more online than aaron and i
um but yeah i not i mean all the stuff
like unfortunate and everything
had had to be approached as a research
project you know yeah
i barely had a myspace account yeah
yeah i never did i never still have
never really
checked got too deep into 4chan but
general social media but yeah never ever
got real deep
yeah georgio keeps things spicy on
twitter yes
yeah yeah so then
uh what so how did you get to a subject
of something that is sort of emblematic
of this
uh you know this online culture
and uh how it
i think this is a really interesting
case study that you picked to discuss
this phenomenon of this sort of like war
of the normies versus the online that's
going on
because it does trace through all the
different eras um
how did you first become aware of it and
did you were you interested in it as
emblematic
or just a as a story in itself
um we first became aware of it through
matt fury's comics so
it is a a movie about folks who are
extremely online but
you know i came to it through a through
a xerox zine you know
bought at i think probably quimby's
books in chicago um
so it was something that uh you know
came out of uh love of matt fury's
original comics
and his artwork and then when i started
to see pepe
pop up uh both in the mainstream media
and then also online in 2015
uh where he was getting retweeted by you
know then presidential candidate donald
trump
there was this moment where this comic
book that i loved had suddenly passed
off the page and into the
sort of vortex of the internet and i
found it to be very confusing
and so uh but we but i like that you say
case study that's a way that i think all
of us talked about the film when we were
uh in the trenches working on it because
we understood that
while it could be an artist story it
could also be a very unique case study
in the way that trolling moved off of
message boards and into mainstream
politics in the 2016 election
yeah yeah i mean that's the thing
um like i was aware of pepe just having
spent a lot of time on reddit and stuff
as a meme and i was
embarrassed when arthur told me about
this project he was working on that i
didn't know anything about
matt's background but like in terms of
like stories to find i think
to me my favorite films are the ones
that are about something very specific
but really talk about a much broader
cultural moment and like pepe is this
uniquely
insane story about something on its face
kind of absurd and silly but actually
like the more you dig into it you really
understand that it speaks to a much
bigger maybe more complicated story that
is otherwise hard to comprehend but
but for the virtue of this silly frog
we're able to tell his story and through
that like
hopefully give people some uh at least
peace of mind or something i don't know
and just timing
and just timing wise it came at such a
time where it felt like so many people
in the online world and in the real
world were confused by what was
happening on this online world and how
we got where we
are right now and so it became the story
that really
simplified and explained it in a very a
very simple way
to kind of help us through these last
four years and
pat this past election too i think
yeah yeah well we jumped right into it
but
while we're talking i just want to go
ahead and introduce everybody and in the
middle of the interview we're mixing it
up a little bit
down here on the bottom left we've got
arthur jones who's the director of the
film
and then in uh center left here we've
got giorgio angelini who's a producer on
the film and you also uh
chair director credit correct there's a
film by arthur and i um
i shot some of it and then wrote wrote
the final song
uh credit song yeah that's great i want
to hear more about that later
and then uh top left we've got uh
producer aaron wickenden
hey hello and then
and then in the center right below my
face we've got
karen papa tosto who's also a producer
on the film
and we're here talking about feels good
man so
let's get back track just a little bit i
thought that was interesting when you
said arthur about the comics because
that's how i heard of pepe too i bought
a uh boys club
at quimby's right oh nice i have one
from i have the
comic that is uh the the panel where he
says feel good number two
issue number two yeah yeah the one
number one really for being honest
sorry about it yes he's doing number one
in issue number two
we're going to try to keep it pg from
here
did being a fan of his his actual work
and not just coming at it as a meme did
that help
kind of sell matt fury on doing the
documentary yeah
i i mean i'd become friends with matt
fury in 2013.
we met through some mutual friends and
my background is um
animation and you know cartooning so
um so i'd been a fan of his stuff and
then while we were setting
out to make feels good man i always
thought that like i was excited to tell
a story
about kind of how cartoons are important
um and i also kind of knew that since i
could do a lot of the animation in the
film
um it would maybe be just a really
resourceful way to make this like
scrappy interesting film and
i also want to say it's a very exciting
thing to you know be
be here sort of in the same room with
aaron and giorgio and karen because to
get this thing made
we all had to wear multiple hats aaron
was the lead editor he was the producer
giorgio
shot a lot of it produced karen was like
a you know out there like beating the
drum for feels good man from the very
beginning and so
it's been um a really collaborative
thing thus far
um so yeah i mean matt
i i presented the idea of making a
documentary to matt and ayanna his
partner who's also an amazing artist and
is featured in the film and i was just i
tried to be as transparent with them as
possible
um just being like this is about how
long it's going to take um these are the
people i hope to sort of be
collaborating with
um you know and they really like um
trusted me in a way that um
thinking back now i'm very kind of
surprised and thankful that they did
obviously because
um you know as i was learning how to be
a director of a documentary matt was
learning how to be a subject of a
documentary and i'm kind of glad we got
to go through it together
yeah so uh let's talk about the
animation in the songs
in the film i think that that's one
thing that really helps
to um it it adds a little something
to the film and being a film about an
artist one would hope
that that art would be part of the thing
and it helps remind
you i think that there is still joy in
art even if it can be used
for these twisted ends right um so how
uh you said you were learning how to
make a documentary arthur so i suppose
you were
kind of learning as you went along uh i
was wondering how
like does introducing an animated
element
um does it change the way that you
assemble it or is it
you know pretty pretty standard um
well i mean i want to throw this
question to aaron because as an editor i
think he had to sort of deal
with with the sort of background yeah
yeah i mean so you know the the extent
to which
like the the original sort of the way
the film gets
layered is you know we had a number of
the primary interviews filmed from
from the beginning when i started
working on it uh we had the the primary
interview with matt ayanna
johnny ryan chris sullivan a couple
others
and um you know i would cut a scene
almost like uh it would have a radio
edit kind of feeling to it
and a rhythm with an understanding that
arthur would be able to take it
and spin it you know along with
ultimately our team of great animators
we worked with
in any kind of different direction and
so that was
kind of both like liberating and also
you know having never worked in that way
like you know it opens up this this you
know endless
possibilities and so for me though like
you know we were cutting it in premiere
and i would just you know google you
know like
pepe you know christmas or pepe you know
all kinds of horrible things as well and
and then you know you would find some
some pretty basic uh jpegs and things
like that
pull them into premiere uh lay them in
and then most of the time
i was doing just the crudest sort of
zoom in
repositions all this kind of stuff where
you know the
image would even be off the side and
there'd be a black bar i mean
really basic basic work and then um
arthur would kind of take it and spin
that into
another another layer like i think one
of the first things that we
actually collaborated on was this the
sequence where
uh pepe pulls his pants down to pee
and arthur came out to chicago so we
could do that like
very very crucial sequence
but it was cool because arthur was set
up in the other room on
like a you know just a table in the
other room and i would i would kind of
cut it for the audio and then hand it to
arthur and then arthur would kind of
do his magic and create this like just
incredible
symphony of imagery and what what i've
always loved about
arthur is like he has a real
ability to communicate visually like the
incredible
amounts of story detail very quickly i
mean maybe i don't know if that's
something
like he could elaborate on but i think
that's that's one of his gifts as an
animator especially
and one of the things for me is an
editor that was really excited uh
exciting in terms of our collaboration i
will elaborate and say that the sound of
when pepe pees and goes ah that's the
sound of aaron
i will elaborate on what aaron said
uncredited
i mean now credited here for film
independence this is like
we couldn't afford your union rape buddy
yeah that's right that's right well i'll
brag about aaron too and that he's just
extremely good at figuring out how to
how how we were going to be able to use
the animation
really intentionally to drive the story
and to be a really specific layer of the
story and he's just
a real expert at that and did a great
job for sure and i
i think working with three established
filmmakers definitely gave me
like a sense of confidence in going into
this project because i knew that i could
just kind of like lean on their
particular expertise
and so the moments that i maybe felt
kind of like ill-equipped to do
something i knew that
um i always had like these that i was
standing on the shoulders of giants so
it was a really nice experience in that
regard
but there was like a there was some the
the
the rationale for animation was
multifaceted right like
we understood from the beginning that
the story was going to be a very
compelling story but it also lent itself
to a creative
problem to solve that we thought would
be really useful and
and uh exciting to explore and like
probably one of the most
uh exciting things to really the nut to
crack was really to figure out how the
animation would weave into the film
without
taking away from the a story and like
initially we really had conceived of
actually a much longer
animated sequence that would have like a
script and have its own sub
narrative and i think we learned very
early on that that was only so much you
could
cram into a film and that actually like
the most important thing that the
animations could do was elevate the
emotionality of the film
because we kind of also knew that the
ending we really wanted to end with pepe
and we wanted to feel like you were
losing
a buddy right and like really get back
to the core of what like good animation
i think is and so
um it was a great like collaboration in
that sense because there was a lot of
trial and error
to get there yeah yeah we wanted um and
aaron's discipline definitely was like a
big part in figuring
that out but we really wanted to make
sure that after you've seen feels good
man
we gave matt fury's artwork the stage
presence that it deserved
and so that you would really have a
sense of even if you've seen pepe as a
meme on the internet
that you will be like oh okay i
understand pepe's backstory i understand
that he came from this very specific
imaginative world made by someone
and we felt like that was always the
thing that pepe needed
there's been a lot of cartoon characters
that have been turned into memes over
the years but those are cartoon
characters that have a bigger presence
within pop culture
and maybe like um you know a huge
corporate ip
behind them to protect their copyright
and pepe's never had that because it was
made by
this kind of like scrappy artist who we
see working in a thrift store like he
didn't have
a lawyer on retainer to fight the people
on reddit who are using it
and so we just wanted the animations to
feel
like they were beautiful and artistic
and they had
um like a real um importance that we
were giving them within the film
that's really interesting what you said
about uh matt fury not having you know
uh lawyers or corporate ip behind him do
you think this film could function
as sort of i hope not i don't think it's
discouraging
i think it's actually very encouraging
to artists but like a sort of a
cautionary tale to artists about you
know
maybe file some paperwork with your
character
well no i'll let's i'll let someone else
in the in the team
he had a copyright it was just about
enforcement right like
and in the beginning in the beginning
like all of us experiencing the internet
it was fun and interesting and pepe was
really just this reaction
image and i think he was kind of
flattered that it was reaching so many
different
uh people in this funny way and then it
wasn't really until things start
started to turn for the dark that he
started to feel like
the anxiety of it all and how he could
deal with it but like
you know he's just a single artist right
and and
there's no there's no large company out
there pumping the
the brand of pepe out there and so it
really took
this catalyzing moment that had to get
so dark that he basically was able
to get really talented lawyers to come
on board and help him for free so that
he could actually fight
his copyright because having the
copyright alone isn't enough right like
he can't you can't spend all day long
and also it's a weird fight right
because so much of it is
is happening in these diffuse
hard-to-understand ways like people on
twitter
just making tweets or creating avatars
like you can't one by one just like hey
could you please uh
maybe not use my my artwork
so it was only until like the more
opportunistic grifters like alex jones
and and richard spencer actually started
using pepe specifically
to either generate revenue or as like
their own
uh logo that he could finally like take
take
concise action
and actually just realizing how
dangerous they that it could actually
become once we have trump
in the white house right now we're like
what just happened
thinking about the difficulty also the
one-on-one challenge reminds me of you
know just even
our challenge to of keeping the film
from being pirated which i think georgio
might be able to speak to really well
you know like at one point
i think we were the second highest
pirated film next to mulan
is that right yeah so giorgio has been
great at trying to kind of
you know talk to talk to people
one-on-one but you know in terms of
enforcement
like you were saying it's it's difficult
it's a full-time job
yeah yeah it is if you flag something on
youtube it doesn't come down
it's more effective to write the person
who posted it
so i mean it definitely came into our
minds as we were thinking about how to
distribute the film being such a viral
character you know we're
we're kind of wondering you know just
putting it up
online would the the film have the same
sort of
virality as pepe himself and you know of
course
that's still something that we're in the
middle of so
uh well here's another question uh for
the folks that were more
um you know doing the production side
maybe for you giorgio
do you agree that spending a lot of time
in
um one could say the darker corners of
the internet is not good for your mental
health
um yeah i don't know i mean i think
mills
our 4chan guy is is a good example of
that i mean
arthur and i spent a week with him in
his basement lair
and i mean i think mills would be the
first person to tell you that
he knows it's unhealthy for him i mean
there's a culture on 4chan of people who
were like
okay i'm i'm see you later guys like i'm
finally swearing off of this thing it's
ruining my life
uh i know it's bad for me and i need to
just like cut
cold turkey and then they come back
weeks later i mean it does have
a striking resemblance to other kind of
addictions right there's a kind of
spiraling
that happens where you're amongst people
who are just kind of always trying to
uh what we call like irony poisoning
irony poison each other and there's kind
of only
it's hard to get out of that right and
and and um
you you would see this shift in mills
personality just
literally from moving throughout his
house he would be upstairs in the
kitchen
with his mom who's as sweet as can be
sort of
midwestern mom making lunch for the
family and his brother who's like a
like a hunky youtube hunter guy
and like they're having a nice family
moment and then he descends down into
the basement and he's just like
he gets locked in and um no i mean i
think for sure there's there's a kind of
sinister quality to the way that
websites not just like 4chan but
honestly
any social media are built to sort of
tease out of you your kind of worst
most uh cynical ways and i think the
film if anything is really just a
reminder to people to say like
like a reconfirmation of humanity and to
say that there's another way to work you
don't
you can reject that cynicism and you
shouldn't feel ashamed to be
um empathetic and authentic
yeah i mean even the thing you said
about people threatening to quit and
then coming back that happens even on
twitter
all the time right yeah with me
[Laughter]
yes well
and also it's interesting you know how
quickly this sort of
culture moves um you know to even
uh tracing the story you trace you know
pepe's uh
evolution from sort of a i call them a
sweet stoner frog in my review
to a a hate symbol and then dead and
back again in this documentary
uh that was ten years and but even over
the course of the year that you made
this thing
when it debuted sundance so much has
changed just in the year like how are
you feeling
about this uh culture that your
documentary it is very tied to donald
trump
as we move forward with biden and harris
how do you what do you think is going to
um where do you think that's going to go
next do you have any ideas
well i mean i certainly there are some
parallels between the 2016
moment that we documented and feels good
man and what happened in 2020
uh the most obvious one is uh you know
in the same way that pepe started as a
joke on 4chan and then sort of like bled
out into the mainstream politics
you know we had q anon sort of starting
on 4chan
initially as a joke and then all of a
sudden became a bigger and bigger
conspiracy theory
um and became part of a mainstream
politics where there's
uh a couple different sort of q and on
adherents who were elected
uh into office so you know
the story of these of trolling and
misinformation coming off of these
message boards and into politics
continues to be something that
um is extremely relevant and only
growing in power
and the way that this sort of attention
economy that these things operate within
allow the most extreme loud voices
within those communities
to just kind of control the discourse is
something that you know
is is something we're all contending
with in in a way
that um is scary like can social media
um figure help help democracy or is it
going to only tear it apart
like i mean these are this is the
subtext it feels good man
i mean you know this is an artist's
story but in the same way that pepe sort
of got snatched from matt
you know we can all recognize the pepes
in our lives that feel like they've been
snatched from us
like you know in some ways we feel
consensus reality has been taken from us
in some of these moments
and so that's why we've always thought
about it like you said before like a
case study
you know this is this is an interesting
way of exploring this like
problem that often seems
incomprehensible but the story of pepe
is a comprehensible way
of talking about it a little silver
lining and hope at the
end of the tunnel for for all of us and
for pepe was
the surprise that happened actually to
us
while making the the film and cutting
the end of the film
we had no idea that the the hong kong
um would would happen and that
you know in the middle in the middle of
trying to figure out what our
ending was going to be mostly uh
thinking about it around
matt's lawsuit with alex jones um
figuring out how we were going to end
the film and land the plane
then hong kong happened which was a
silver lining for pepe and
a new beginning in a way and a good
ending for us
so maybe the same thing we'll repeat
uh repeat another happy cycle
okay you're muted katie you're muted
i'm on muted thinking oh um
well you know we're talking about all
this and something that i'm wondering is
so this story like you know we talk
about a case study and multi-layered and
all these different things
that like in the subtext were you
conscious like how did you
sort of navigate balancing the
on the one this kind of like sweet
biographical documentary
uh with two um
you know a political story and then
three you have
this deep very deep philosophical
underbase about
the mutability of reality like how
how did those thread how did you tease
out those threads
and kind of balance them in the film
yeah i'll jump in there so i mean in
terms of the
structure of the film you know from the
beginning we always knew we were going
to be
using this as a case study following you
know matt and his
uh as you know our primary character um
we didn't know
how close to matt's story or how far
away we could go
so we started putting the film together
and kind of you know made some
discoveries in the edit
i think we found that like you know in
the film you could only
you know you could only drift so far
from matt and that story and how
these sort of mutations of pepe and
uh what was happening to him over time
there's only so far you could drift from
that before you would start to kind of
lose the thread of what the
film was so um the the
way we built out the movie was to have
uh these very
like discreet you know mutate you know
mutations of the character
you know where pepe went from sort of
being mats
to you know being someone else's and we
talked about it like as if
uh someone was sort of putting pepe on
like a puppet and then making him do
something else
and then how did that impact matt and
then the character would mutate again
and so you know that is generally like
the underlying structure of the film
that sort of cause and effect
relationship and
um that's that's what sort of animates
the energy of the story
and then artistically we just tried to
do things that
um um to to emphasize that cause and
effect
and there were things that we utilized
to do that one was music
one was like the music and the sections
with matt have a different sort of like
instrumentation
and feeling to it than the than the way
the music functions in the more digital
space
um you know we have like a little bit
more quiet there's a little bit more
breathing room in those sections
if we're going to utilize animation in
those in those situations
um we're going to try to make it feel
very different than the motion graphics
that we might have used when we're
talking about the sort of
energy of the internet and so um
using this sort of like analog versus
digital
kind of approach um made a very
complicated film
very like modular and and it felt like
something that we could
tackle without sort of like losing the
thread it was a real um
gift as we were um figuring it figuring
it out
to to have matt and pepe as this sort of
like
um anchor to the movie
i still feel so bad for his his friend
who got the tattoo
don't feel mad for don't feel bad for
chris don't feel bad for chris for a
second
don't do it
chris is doing great chris is chris is
always doing great
but you know i was just gonna say when
we premiered the film at sundance you
know they
they allow you to go kind of to these
different uh photo sessions and stuff
like that
and there was one that was like a pizza
hut sponsored photo session
and chris got more swag than anybody
around he had the hat he had the sweater
the scarf he was like fully decked out
in pizza hut here
for the entire you know stay in park
city yeah it was great actually at the
premiere he was sitting right in the
middle
of the the audience and he's a tall guy
and he and so and he has like the hair
and everything and
it was great to just he was he loved the
film
he was clapping he was standing up it
was it was
a huge relief i think to us as
filmmakers to see that the subjects were
having such
a a a a good time watching it
yeah it's really hard not to um not to
love the
these guys they come across so lovable
and even the
um you know the sort of like the the the
ford
chain characters and the guy who buys
the he buys the pepe
bitcoin and all this stuff aside from
you know the obvious villains like alex
jones
was were
were you trying not to demonize these
people too much
i think uh yeah that was really
i was certainly with mills i don't know
we were more
i don't think it's a documentary i don't
think it's a documentarian's job to
demonize people
yeah i mean i think we were interested
in exploring the the systems
that would allow someone to become um
indoctrinated like what is it
happening on a societal level that would
put someone in the basement for this
many
hours on end um and
you know we tried to play it as we're
trying to let people tell their own
stories and just
let people make their own minds up um
you know i think from the very beginning
uh
we wanted to make sure that this film
didn't feel like scoldy
you know that it that it could be
something that like maybe
maybe it's naive but i think it's borne
out to be the case that like it could be
a movie that everyone could watch and
really like
think about fairly and not and not
rather than a film that would like
make people defensive and uh and feel
like they're being attacked or something
like that and so
um that was like a very conscious effort
i think on our part but for alex jones
it's just like
you know anyway we just let him tell his
own story too he does it justice he does
no one does a better job
of making alex jones the villain than
alex jones himself so
i just wanted to add like you know um
and maybe be
like useful to know this for this
particular audience like
editorially it was challenging at the
beginning and with
early edits to um to
land the right balance with how math was
presented in the film
because you know he can seem or come
across
as a passive character you know not
making
you know active choices and um
and in that way being kind of uh
unattached to kind of the story we were
trying to tell
and i think one of one of the ways we
knew that the film had kind of found
its balance is people were able to
understand him well enough
and understand who he was you know his
soul
a bit and and and and relate to why he
wouldn't
like understand why he wouldn't respond
at first and i think that was our our
challenge as filmmakers was to frame
that in the right way
so that you understood and related to
that like you know
yeah he's he wasn't a person who was on
4chan so why would he be responding
right away
um but it took a while to find that
balance and
and you know it's it's a challenge for
filmmakers to
present your character in a way that
where their their actions you know are
framed correctly
and honestly yeah i mean arthur often
says like
the film is an emotional journey an
emotional journey of pepe
and people's emotional relationship to
pepe so i think the truth
behind the way we rendered each
character hopefully is
showing their emotions like how they
relate to the story and i think
you know people can come away with
whatever opinions they want about the
people but i think
you know the emotional truth we hope was
rendered in each character
and we also had these amazing gifts like
um you know it's a documentary film
about social media and the internet but
within it we have a death
it's a death of a sad silly frog that we
handle in a way that in some ways seems
very sincere but in other ways there's
like
a layer of you know winking in that
section or the section with alex jones
we approach that as like all right this
is
this is our shootout moment or this is
our fist fight um this is the moment of
conflict and you know
i think this was a really unique film
and where
as filmmakers we could sort of see like
how do we take
this story and figure out a way to to
turn it into like a very compelling
movie
that operated as like a very satisfying
narrative arc and because we had pepe
this malleable wonderful funny hilarious
character at the center of it
it gave us a lot of chances
for us as artists to sort of see
ourselves within this story
and bring it to life in a way that we
felt was like going to be satisfying for
hopefully everybody yeah i think to also
try and expand it beyond the
universe of people who already knew and
either loved or hated pepe
but then to also engage a broader
audience of people who
wouldn't normally perhaps pick up the
comic book or
look at or be into memes or the silly
frog or animation or anything
but to understand to to broaden the
understanding that this was a bigger
story about the world we live in and the
internet world we live in
and to get other people interested who
may not initially click on
a movie like this so yeah like i showed
the film to my parents who were you know
in
in their late 60s early 70s and they
they had no idea of any of the stuff and
it really
helped them understand like why why the
world is the way it is right now
i will say though that aaron's mom
helped us find the cryptocurrency guys
that's right that her that her google
sleuthing product brought us
pepe cash millionaire so oh wow
this was this was a team effort
well on that same note we're going to
take a few audience questions and
there's one thing i think
leads into this one very nicely uh riley
asks
uh 4chan being as anonymous as it is
is difficult to put a face to you
included a real 4chan user as an
interview subject who played a fairly
big role in the documentary
can you talk about the process of
finding the subject and why it was
important to include him
thank you we felt like it was important
to include um someone who
had used pepe um and had cared about
pepe
and felt like um we knew that someone
like
like mills would be able to sort of like
demystify a part of the story that a lot
of people were very confused by they
were like why how could people be so
upset by this cartoon frog
um and then what was the sort of like
machinations behind the scenes
that turn that kind of weaponized pepe
and so
um from the very beginning uh my hope
was to not
focus on the provocateurs of the moment
of the movement
like richard spencer which been appeared
in a number of other documentary
films but we wanted to focus on the
people that
richard spencer or his ilk would seek to
exploit
this was the audience of disaffected
guys who were unhappy with their
conditions
and were susceptible to the sort of
brotherhood of white supremacy or
something like this
or they were susceptible to the trolling
aesthetics of it
and so that's why we felt like it was
important mills though is someone if you
are
on 4chan for a period of time you'll see
photos of mills mills
is a meme within 4chan he himself is a
meme
and so um the the person who question is
correct it's mostly an anonymous
platform
but mills faces on it so he he become he
became sort of a de facto
4channer and um you know there was this
one video that i stumbled upon when i
was like searching through youtube
archives
that was just labeled with a date and it
only had a handful of views
and it was the the video in which mills
is holding up his phone
and he's it's before he's about to go to
bed and
um he says what does pepe mean to me and
i was watching it in my studio
at night everyone was asleep in the
house and
i felt like mills was talking to me and
there was this moment where i was like
um he's going to be in the movie he's
going to be in the movie
and um so that was
i don't know that's that's the way it
happened and i know that it's probably
uncomfortable for some people to see it
but mills is representative
of a lot of people who are in this
country right now who feel lost
who feel like don't they don't know how
to access the part of america
that they've always believed they were
entitled to they don't know how to like
access the part of america that's going
to give them a good job or get them a
house or get them out of the basement
and part of that anger creates like this
reactionary force in the united states
and they're part of this coalition
that's happening because they feel like
they're on the outside
looking in and um we wanted people to
understand the emotion of it
because pepe became the avatar for
grievance and anger in america during
this brief moment in 2016
and it's because there are a lot of
people who feel angry and the internet
knows how to amplify
anger um in a way that has never been
seen on a global scale before
the attention economy will amplify anger
to like an irrational
end and so um you know someone like
mills is very susceptible to this um
you know form of extreme and edgy
communication
and so um that's yeah that's why he's
important
yeah like the the truth that was what
made mills character so difficult to
tell because the truth
like i was saying earlier the truth of
mill's a story they wanted to tell was
his emotions
right because that's his emotional truth
what was less interesting was
the agreement the bullshit right like
the sense of entitlement or the sense
that he's being wronged right like those
are not important because those are like
those are manipulations of his uh
emotional state right and we wanted to
really interrogate
like what happens in those emotional
states and why these things are
happening
so like it made it made him a very
tricky character to edit but one i
we all thought was like super important
to include because
you know this is like the center of the
issue that we're all kind of confronting
now is how we deal with this
like unfortunately very vibrant
pulsating anger that's happening online
and and like you know it's not it's not
going away
and it's not to say that we need to
capitulate to it or
to sympathize with it but
it is to understand it is vital
aaron did you have something to add um
yeah i mean i was
i was just gonna say you know on on a
storytelling level there's also a really
big difference
um when you're working on a film and
someone is very close to an experience
versus someone is sort of studying
or analyzing an experience and um on the
films i work on
you know you try to kind of bring the
audience in as closely as possible
to sort of like proximity of experience
so with someone like mills being able to
say like
you know to speak in the eye like i used
pepe to do this
you know i observed this moment where he
became the smug pepe and this is what
that meant to me
it's it's so different than when you
have somebody standing outside of that
saying you know
they did this or i saw this happen you
know it's it's sort of
far from the the experience and i think
that
one one thing we were conscious of with
the film on a
technical level was just trying to kind
of like modulate
those two things so you had had dale
uh who was um you know giving you who
had studied
uh who has studied 4chan at length and
you know come throughout the film to
give you that
perspective so to be able to modulate
between
the lived experience and a closely
observed experience
well let's get a couple more questions
here one here is a very technical
uh so i'll ask this one first how did
you get the alex jones deposition
footage if you can say
and whose permission if any did you need
to include it this sounds like a
question from a documentarian or an
aspiring one
uh through fair use i mean the lawyers
uh
provided it to us there's basically like
it becomes public record unless
uh you know you file it otherwise and
alex jones didn't file it otherwise so
it just became part of like
uh discovery essentially so um yeah
yeah shout out to katie alhamdidi who is
our fair use attorney
she is uh she's the best um
but it's it's incredible i mean i cannot
tell you the the
joy of why i mean because they're like
three plus hours each and like there is
so much incredible stuff there like
cutting when we first saw the first cut
of the back and forth between matt
matt and alex like there are like six
different versions of that and each one
is
equally hysterical for completely
different reasons it was really hard
to decide how to uh how to how to choose
but like the
again the emotional truth of that is
basically like just showing that
matt just being cool as a cucumber like
going up against
the the final final boss of sorts and
that like
here's alex jones who actually doesn't
give an f about anything
any of it at all like he even though
that positions happening in his own
office he showed up an hour late
you know he wasn't prepared for it like
that all of this is farce
right like that's what was so awesome
about the way
uh aaron and our and our other editors
uh
drew and katrina like treated that scene
as it it
it is like looking in the mirror of the
internet farce right it's like saying
here here it is all this is meaningless
don't take this
asshole seriously he literally doesn't
care he's just trying to sell you like
bone broth supplements
okay and then one more question that's
for everybody and this one's a little
more lighthearted but i think it
is applicable because this movie left me
feeling
hopeful like more hopeful than i
expected in the first half by the end i
was like
oh um anyway
uh rebecca asks when you see pepe now
what is your initial emotion
oh i always thought pepe was love from
the very beginning because i just felt
like i really fell in love with
the the comic books and then matt as a
character
and and his family and i always felt
like so
mad that the internet did this to pepe
when i just because i connected with the
the main character of our story so much
show her your tattoo karen well we did
do
like well and now it's upside down see i
should have got it the other way
no wait no there we go i got pepe we did
tattoos at sundance it was really fun
oh wow oh that's so funny i brought it
up like it was a problem
and you all have them you know because
that's the thing i thought
you know we all really did um you know
just see the
integrity of the character and the you
know genuine reason why
how and why matt created him and and
fell in love with him and i do love that
he gets that treatment at the end that
he's he is like and
i love that he's an omen for good and um
hopefulness at the end of our film so
yeah yeah i'll add
for me um you know i think matt says
this at the end of the movie but
you know pepe has changed and the film
you know even
even though it has this direct
connection to
uh the you know political environment
that we're in
um you know it's a it's also a
meditation on
an individual's like ability to navigate
and deal with change
on a personal level and in that way i
find it also really beautiful
and useful and so pepe for me
is is that opportunity to you know
see things as um as
mutable i you know i think matt says
uh you know pepe won't always be this
way or something
like that there won't always be humans
on this planet
and they're just that ability to kind of
like abstract out that far
and think about that you know during
this time with
you know covet and just so many extremes
it's helpful to think that that all of
this will be different
and you know we have a lot of life ahead
of us
yeah i'm really satisfied i mean i'm
glad that the movie
left you with a sense of hope because i
think that
um you know
we wanted this film to have a sense of
poetry to it
and um you know there were you know
there's been a lot of movies made about
the internet
and then there's been a lot of sci-fi
movies sort of where um
there's a dystopian instinct that takes
over like the algorithms the machines
have taken over and there's no going
back
and um we wanted very self-consciously
for this movie not to sort of embrace
that and we wanted to realize like this
is a moment that we have willpower over
both as filmmakers
and then hopefully in a larger capacity
within society
and so um you know pepe leaving the film
leaving matt leaving the audience with
this beautiful sunset
was a artistic choice that we made and
giorgio wrote the song at the end of it
and our animators did an amazing job
bringing that to life
and that was something that was a gift
for matt and hopefully like a gift for
the viewer that's the way that we were
we were hoping for it and i've
always loved pepe i never he's never
been a hate symbol to me but he is the
symbol of an underdog and i recognize
that that's kind of like
um powerful but um yeah i mean
i'm happy to have pepe in my life i have
pictures of pepe up in the house
um you know it's it's it's something
that brings me a lot of joy and this
film has brought me a lot of joy and the
collaborations within it have brought me
a lot of joy so for me pepe is a gift
i mean it's insane i would say just to
back up
to this whole story in general just to
think that like
a guy in his 20s making a xerox
cartoon ends up creating
a character that is now probably
the top 10 most recognizable cartoon
characters around the world and he's
never spent
maybe like six to seven hundred dollars
like promoting
the film i mean the cartoon in its life
like
that there's a power to the cartoon
itself and that people see in it some
kind of
uh on wii or whatever it is like there's
power to cartoons and there's powers
to images and like what happened in 2015
2016 was
really i think just like an aberration
and a much longer story about
like really this powerful incredible
piece of art that matt created he tapped
into something
i don't know clearly and
well i just want to end by
congratulating all of you on the film i
think it is it does a wonderful job of
conveying the emotion that you all were
talking about
and also really just wrapping up a very
complicated issue in a very compelling
narrative so congratulations to all of
you
and just one more time we have with us
aaron
hey thank you katie really appreciate it
and i see there's like 31 participants
right now so
shout out to all the film independent
and then georgio
thank you everyone really appreciate the
questions uh karen
thank you and arthur
yeah thanks for the great questions
everybody
thanks for watching the movie thanks for
uh yeah thanks for this
pandemic hang on
it's all been a labor of love we put
this film out ourselves and it's like
really moving that
we're here and that there's 30 to one oh
now 30 participants thank you all for
coming to join us we're losing us we're
listening
we're losing oh no
[Laughter]
are there any other um screenings of the
film coming up if someone
uh saw this and wanted to you know tell
their friends
uh we're organizing them just checking
on our social media we're
we've said we built a website to be able
to do really great
live try to make the the virtual
experience as
in person as possible so we're always
looking for opportunities to have
special screenings and we're working
actively with different organizations
and and
individuals to host fun q and a's like
this so um
and shout out to pbs itvs who've been
great partners the bbc has been a great
partner um and people can
rent it you know that's that would be
nice
perhaps consider renting it or it's the
holidays you could buy a blu-ray
future amazing deleted scenes so
all your friends who are bootlegging our
movie to stop
yeah you can send us a bitcoin donation
that goes into the waterfall our eps
will be super happy shout out to
wavelength productions
the wonderful wavelength productions
film possible oh yeah the soundtrack
beautiful
the soundtrack the beautiful soundtrack
by arie bellusion and brian hope
um is a great beautiful and dystopian
listen
a good a good christmas gift for the
audio files in your life what else can i
hustle
we've got listeners we got koozies you
can listen to them we've got a shirt
let's do this yeah sharon vanetten track
the closing track let go is now
available and we'll be coming out on
seven inch vinyl
through mondo as well soon and isn't her
is it that that song that you guys wrote
together isn't that
now in her top like five yeah
it's in the top five songs in the uh
worldwide above
um the more you listen to it you'll
forget that other music exists
you won't even realize that like the
rolling stones or the monkeys wherever
it is
you're hearing that song over and over
again
well thank you very much anyway it's
getting a little punchy but thank you
thanks everybody for joining me